thanks carter lawmakers in washington
are set for a critical day of talks in
their battle over a new stimulus plan
while tens of millions of americans
face uncertainty over their extra
unemployment benefits
new cbs news polling shows 83 percent of
adults across
party lines want congress to pass a new
coronavirus economic relief package
paula reeds at the white house paula are
they close to getting this done
good morning anthony lawmakers do not
appear to be close to getting
this deal done but today republicans are
expected to present their opening offer
to democrats
a long-awaited 1 trillion stimulus
package
and good news for many americans it is
expected to include
another round of twelve hundred dollar
checks but the sticking point
has been the six hundred dollar per
person per week federal jobless benefit
that's set to expire
the white house gop lawmakers they claim
that amount of money discourages people
from trying to go back to work instead
the white house says
it will present a benefit that would be
no more
than 70 percent of whatever the wages
were that you were making before you
lost your job
but house speaker nancy pelosi says that
republican formula is way too
complicated for the system
as part of their proposal though
republicans are also expected to extend
the moratorium on evictions which would
allow some people to remain
in their homes until they can get back
on their feet republicans have floated
the idea of possibly doing
a narrow piece of legislation and then
going back to deal with some of these
other issues
but speaker pelosi has flatly rejected
that idea
signaling a long road ahead jerica
paula thank you wonder what people are
going to do with their kids even as they
do go back